in omixlogic community as i said it's a
free community anyone can join for free
here you can see register for free
but uh there are premium courses which
requires you to utilize the
uh tbanfor server so there's a
subscription for the program
a minimal a very minimal cost that we
have kept together and that's why we are
calling it a special
opportunity for you to learn from us and
learn from the resources that are
available
so you can join the program to access
the premium courses otherwise you will
have access to the free courses
i will tell you which free courses and
how you can access those as well once
you have created a login
i'll do that but before that i mean if
you are interested in going through the
entire
you know sessions going through the
workshops by experts
going through the premium courses and
all of that then you have to join the
program
through this page and it's kind of
simple
so let me show you i'm already a part of
the program
so if i have to join the program how can
i join you obviously you'll have to
log in from your account first and then
you will see the program page and once
you go
in this program page or
if you can also like go to the link
directly you will be able to come to
this program page
and then you will have to complete your
registration
so you can give your information and
you we will be sending you more
information about the program more
details if you are
not sure about what will be covered and
at the same time you can start your
application and you book your seat
so it's a program that will be available
for anyone to take
and you can join this entire whatever we
covered in today's session will be
available with a beginner's license so
we have different subscription levels
so the first beginner subscription level
is just for ten dollars a month which
will give you access to all of the
things that we discussed today
and we have different other subscription
levels for you to do research
for you to do work on project and uh
maybe we will discuss it in the next
time when we meet
but for this program you will be able to
do all the course work and
all the live sessions that we just
discussed and
about the coursework i'm going to tell
you what all coursework are there which
are for free and which are for premium
and why they are premium
and why there is a cost so let me go
back to the slide deck
yeah the first course that we have put
together for everyone to take
is a free course uh other than the ones
that you've seen star or the premium
ones
so uh when you do this course and go
through this course bytes and molecule
you get an
overview of a very basic understanding
about the different data types that we
will be discussing
in the program so anyone coming from a
background
without a knowledge of biology can start
taking this
course bytes and molecules so let me
just quickly show you a video
for the same
bytes and molecules
every living cell has its own hard drive
where it stores
bites of information needed to function
and grow adapt to environmental changes
and fight off dangerous intruders this
information is stored in molecules that
are arranged in sequences of letters
referred to as dna code in the 1990s a
tremendous effort by governments
researchers
and companies resulted in the full
sequence of the human genome
since then we've seen an exponential
growth of molecular data that describes
cells
tissue organs and organisms massive data
sets containing genetic information
about the young old healthy
and sick are now freely available to the
public
here we will explore the various omics
data types as well as examples of the
information they contain
genomic variants associated with
ancestry gene
expression levels responsible for cancer
spread and protein modifications that
can render
important code unreadable this course is
intended for all those interested in
understanding how the current revolution
in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health
so as you learn from this this is the
first course that you will go through
and it's a free course anyone can take
and in this course you will learn about
the different data types
another free course that we have is the
introduction to bioinformatics
uh it's a course that takes you through
different types of
you know application of bioinformatics
big data bioinformatics as i said
and it's a course where we get to learn
about you your
uh expectations what do you want to
learn in bioinformatics
which area of research that you are
interested in
so this course has a form when you start
this taking this course
uh you will get a form and i'll request
to sonalika to share maybe the
link to this course as well so this is
an introductory course
where you will get the overview of
different type of
fields where you can apply
bioinformatics and you can also tell us
about your
uh area of research where you are
interested in
so these two courses uh is something
that you
we would want you to start with uh even
if you are joining the program even if
you're not
joining the program it will be really
helpful for you to go through these
courses
so once you go through this courses uh
we also have
other free courses introductory courses
for r for omics bioinformatics as
i said that in this program you will
also have opportunity to learn coding
you will have also uh have an
opportunity to
learn uh this from the browser itself
and get points and recognition and all
of that
by while completing this coursework so
in the
this first tutorial which is just to get
started with bioinformatics
it tells you about you know loading
structural data into our
a multi-dimensional data visualization
in our
readings a very uh basic uh file
uh dna file yeah and then understanding
the dna replication and reverse
complement
complements in r so this is if
here also you will have free courses
where you can learn about these
different technologies uh and how it can
be applied
different programming languages how it
can be applied for data visualization
now i mean i told you about the premium
courses as well so the premium courses
how they can help you
do the hands-on analysis on on yourself
by yourself at your own pace
so let's take a look at that let's have
a demonstration about that as well
so let's go to the learn portal again
and uh
now what we will do is that we will go
to the section called
courses and we will find all the courses
that we are interested in
if you are interested in python we can
try python if you are interested in
r we can do r if you're learning one
want to learn about the introduction to
bioinformatics and genomics
and then epigenomics then all of this
course material
is here we will just have to search for
them
and and i'll show you
that's pretty simple
okay i'll have to log in first
so i'm logged in now i can see the
courses
so let's take a look at the our course
so we have different courses as i said
getting started with our
another course is introduction to data
science
using our now we have a lot of
lessons within these courses that you
can take
and earn points from so let me show you
how it works
and how it is so simple and easy to do
this that anyone can learn from this
because when you start from you know
basic
you tend to get an understanding of
what's going on and you understand
different type of
uh different type of commands that are
being used and get familiarized with it
so we start with uh you know you can
install
r locally on your computer as well and
try this out
and you can do this from the browser
itself as well
so with every tutorial that you see here
the first part is the about is to
understand the problem what the problem
is all about
what we are doing here so we are doing
we are looking at different type of uh
data categorical data or continuous data
in data science and then
we are trying to do some plotting to see
the characteristics of data
i mean how they are uh placed if we can
you know separate them or not
so this is being used in many of the
bioinformatics application in many
bioinformatics application
especially when we are doing big data
analysis so
here i mean you will learn to upload the
data
how you can use links and uh upload that
data into the
into the in into the browser
and then you can run different sort of
commands
to analyze that data so once we learn
about these different commands which is
just shown here you
can go through them and easily learn
about them
then there is a breakdown of code that
will be used for this tutorial
so what this code is doing so it
actually explains all of it and what
kind of
results that we can expect and what kind
of uh
analysis that we can do from this sort
of data
so once you do this uh you get to a
point that
where you can practice it yourself so
it's a
cool playground where you can write your
own code and
you can load data and you can run the
analysis here itself
to show that if if you're getting the
result or not as you see
as as you like as you can see that this
is already a
code that is uh put together and is
working you can change this
and you can run your own code and do
your own analysis downstream analysis
using this code code blocks
and different tutorials that have been
shown here
that have been shown here in the learn
portal that you will have access to
so uh the opportunity is there is a lot
of opportunity to learn about different
things
so i just told you about uh this r code
now let me go back to the uh to the
slides
and i'll show you what all different
courses that we have put together for
you to take so uh you can start from
python as well similar courses
you can apply and see what is the
difference how you can learn
both of them and uh i mean choose what
you are
i mean more comfortable in and what kind
of analysis that you are
into and what kind of research that
requires to
use these uh languages and apply
these languages for data analysis so
another
thing another important aspect of this
uh
this sort of learning omics logic
bioinformatics training
is to be able to access the tbi info
platform
and run your own analysis and get the
structured data to analyze further in
r and python so when we go through
uh these courses such as genomics
as i said in the second session after
the introduction session we will be
doing
genomics so in genomics we will be going
through
very basic starts from the dna structure
and variants
why we are using the genomic technology
genomics technology
and where it has been helped helpful how
we can identify variants
and identify mutations that are critical
learning about that working using art
then introduction to genomics
where you get an overview of all of that
in much more detail in depth
and then practicing using the pipelines
as i was telling you that you will be
getting an overview and understanding of
how by how algorithms are connected
together
and they give us a result
a structured result after doing a
complete analysis
so there are several tutorials and the
ones that are starred
uh includes practical uh assignments
so for that you will be able to access
the t by info server
to uh to run some example pipelines and
now let me take you to the t by info
server
and show you how it works and why it is
so easy for anyone to use
i mean even students ban without a
background in bioinformatics
and computational i mean in
computational sciences can do this so
this is the tibia info server and
once you register we will be sharing uh
the access
for you to take some of the example
pipelines from here
and now let me show you an example
pipeline from the transcriptomics data
analysis
so it's an ai guided uh platform and we
have put together examples from
publications
that you can take and learn from and at
the same time you learn about the logic
so many of these algorithms that you see
here are open source algorithms so our
purpose is not to
make you dependent on a platform for
data analysis but
make it simple so that you understand
how the algorithms are used
what are the outcome what are the
outputs that you get from this sort of
analysis
and how to interpret that result so
understand the logic behind the analysis
is what we are focused on that's why we
are called umix logic
and uh to do this i mean we have put
together many examples for you to go
through
one of the examples that i'm taking you
through is the cell line data set
so it's a rna-seq experiment where the
scientists
or the researchers have generated data
on cell line using cell line breast
cancer cell line
um
samples and then we are processing the
raw data here
using these pipelines so we have already
put together
different sections for different sort of
analysis for example
pre-processing mapping quantification
these are different
uh sections that you have to
go through to process data and get a
structured table and now
one thing that you can see is that they
are differently colored
so to make it more easy and simple they
are color coded so that you understand
that
these sections are used for
pre-processing these sections are used
for mapping
this is for quantification of expression
level and what are
all of these steps and we will be going
through in detail in other in the
workshop session
and also they are described i mean
absolutely amazingly in the courses
that you will have access and you will
have go through you'll have
the opportunity to go through in this
training so
uh the input file and the output file
are already stored because the example
pipeline for you to learn
so the first step that we do in such
analysis is to
clean the data make it more structured
so we use
uh algorithms such as dramatic pcr clean
and then i'm going to show you how we
can map it to the transcriptome
and then generate a table of expression
so if you can see i i should be little
slow i know
but uh it's a quick demonstration and
we'll be going through this
in much more detail in the session and
it's described in the courses as well
but here also you will be able to learn
about these
uh these pipelines these algorithms what
they do
what paper that you can read about them
also
and learn about them in much more detail
uh so here
uh what we did is that we pre-processed
the data
we mapped it to a transcriptome and we
when we say if we are mapping or
aligning it to a transcript term
we are doing it on a reference
transcript term and then we are
generating a table of expression after
doing the
uh alignment or the comparison and then
we are doing
ending the pipeline and here you will
see that there are different courses
that you can take
and go through which are on the learn
portal now
uh during the session we will be able to
tell you the
output and how to exp how to uh you know
analyze these
results and what is the outcome and what
can you do
next so the next step is to take this
data structure table
run some other analysis and do some
machine learning analysis based on the
research that we are looking going
through so
this is the way we uh kind of go and
explore the tiva info platform
and obviously it has also the capability
to
to do the analysis right from ncbi so
you can upload data from ncbi
you can upload data from your own
research lab and those
are available with different
subscription options
to access this platform with the program
you will be able to use it for
educational purpose you can be
you'll be able to do example pipelines
and learn first
before you do your own experiments so
that's the process that we follow
for you to go through the technology uh
first
go through the steps uh do the data
analysis on example projects
and then learn on your own or public
data that is available
and that we discussed that it's so huge
that we have been able to do
a lot of quality research out of that
data so this is about the tbi info
platform that you will have access to
and this is this is the coursework for
genomics and then we have the coursework
for
uh metagenomics it's very elaborated
coursework
as as i was telling you there are
examples here that you can learn from
and learn about the opu's learn about
different types of metagenomic analysis
learn about the data to pipeline filo
seek all of this is compare
is covered in different uh tutorials
under this section so if you go to the
course for metagenomics
you will find all of them but together
that you can take one by one
and learn about and apply this to your
own research once you've been able to
do go through this material which is
mostly hands-on
and also gives an overview of all the
technology and there are also videos in
the tutorials
uh so you will be able to go through the
videos uh recorded videos
and replicate that using the t-band for
platform
because at the same time you will have
an access to do this hands-on thing
so that's why the so mixed logic
training is a really unique opportunity
to learn uh for real so the next
uh technology that we will be covering
is the transcriptomics technology
and we have detailed explanation of this
transcript of
transcriptomics data analysis we've been
doing several programs
and uh have a lot of participants who
have gone through this
training and come up with unique
projects that have been published
as well as uh got recognition in various
conferences and
presentations so another aspect of doing
an advanced level analysis is to learn
about
uh the application of machine learning
and uh
we use different type of machine
learning regression uh
so their factor regression analysis
supervised machine learning
unsupervised machine learning uh to kind
of
get insights and results from
transcriptomics data analysis
another advanced section that is again
available
i mean uh as i said it's a
subscription-based model if you are
into this then you can go in deep into
this and maybe
you know try different courses run some
ideas that
share with us some research ideas that
we can work on so there are different
ways we can
collaborate and do research together so
singles and transcriptomics is such an
area very promising area
a lot of modern research and high
value research is coming out of high
impact researches coming out of single
cell analysis
and there's a lot of data that has been
deposited as well
so uh another uh aspect of doing this
all of this is to learn
machine learning how you can apply
machine learning by ml
that that is also is in there in the
course work
so you will also have opportunity i know
that there is a lot of course work that
you can do and learn from
so you can also take your time and go
through this analysis at your own pace
and at the same time learn from the
video that will be recorded and
provided to you um and we will have also
mentors that you can you know connect
with
and learn about specific sort of
analysis
all those opportunities uh are available
uh on
with us for this omixlogic training
so um that is about the work that is
there
uh other than that i have already told
you about the data science part
uh for r and python and then we have uh
mentors
uh that and then we have programs and
which uh which which i can show you
actually quickly
here on the website uh so
when when you're logged in you have
option to do coursework
you have option to select a program and
you have option to do research
so we believe that it's best to start
with the coursework go through the
examples
and then conduct your own research and
learn from specialization programs
one of such program is this one that is
omics logic bioinformatics and
computational biology
people interested in infectious diseases
data science transcriptomics
we have specialization programs that we
keep on doing
as well for those but uh to those who
are
just started this is a best opportunity
for you to take
omislogic bioinformatics and
computational biology
so that was about